wir haben über schwerpunkt themen
gesprochen und die wir setzen wollen um
uns eben auch als etwas kleinere
oppositionspartei im deutschen bundestag
setzen zu können neben der cdu das ist
natürlich eine völlig neue situation für
uns damit haben wir uns auseinander
gesetzt und dort auch lösungsvorschläge
abgeleitet heute haben wir unsere
schwesterpartei aus österreich zu gast
dort haben wir auch sehr viel gelernt
haben schnittstellen
herausgearbeitet die fpö ist ja deutlich
älter als die afd wir verstehen uns eben
auch beide als freiheitliche parteien
freiheitliche fraktion sind dort auch in
den corona maßnahmen sind wir dort davor
dass wir einen freiheitlichen bestimmung
schools haben in freiheit dass jeder
selbst entscheiden kann über seinen
körper auch zu bestimmen und haben uns
auch über weitere
schnittmengen ausgetauscht und werden
diesen dialog zukünftig proaktiv
zwischen der fpö und der afg fraktion
noch fortsetzen heute ist eine
delegation hier mit dem
stellvertretenden fraktionsvorsitzenden
herren wurde hier im in berlin und wir
werden einen gegenbesuch abstatten dann
in wien und unsere zusammenarbeit
vertiefen aber vielleicht dazu mehr herr
wurden sie haben das wort
danke nochmal für die einladung aus es
geht uns auch darum hier vielleicht
unterstützend in deutschland mitzuhelfen
um diesen kurs den wir in österreich
glaube ich sehr erfolgreich seit
jahrzehnten führen auch hier in
deutschland ein bisschen mitzuhelfen und
es waren sehr sehr interessanter
gedankenaustausch heute und die
gegeneinladung steht im frühjahr in wien
und ich glaube ich gerade jetzt in
zeiten von corona ist es wichtig dass
die vernünftigen kräfte hier zusammen
halten
vielleicht noch mal ganz kurz ergänzend
was auch die strategie natürlich angeht
was ein hauptthema waren hauptthema
natürlich auch für uns als jetzt
freibads richtig angedeutet als kleinere
oppositionspartei aber wir verstehen uns
ähnlich wie die fpö
in österreich als die echte
oppositionspartei denn die thematischen
unterschiede das sehen wir ja im
deutschen bundestag zur cdu und der
aktuellen koalition sind ja nicht so
groß wenn wir auch jetzt erleben wie wir
als afd bezugnehmend auf die
ausschussbesetzung weiter ausgegrenzt
werden nicht besetzung haben können also
die themen heimat sind wichtige
programmpunkte
patriotismus genauso wie aber auch das
thema soziale gerechtigkeit was nach
gronau und das sind die themen die wir
natürlich auch ansprechen wollen und
werden weil es wird ja auch eine zeit
nach gegeben die kollateralschäden
werden ein wichtiger punkt für die
bevölkerung werden die steigenden
explodierenden energiepreise
verbraucherpreise also wir haben wir
natürlich auch unsere taktik abgestimmt
und da waren unsere freunde aus
österreich dabei eine große hilfe wir
fokussieren uns auf unser freiheitliches
programm was
unternehmerfreundlich ist was
wirtschaftsfreundlich ist wir sind die
partei des mittelstandes und wir sind
auch eben gerade in diesen corona fragen
eine partei der gastronomie des
einzelhandels da wir als einzige
fraktion überhaupt diese maßnahmen
kritisieren nochmal zusammengefasst wir
halten diese corona maßnahmen die so
einschränken sind für für extrem
wirtschaft schädlich und wir müssen aus
dieser spirale unbedingt raus kommen das
sind wir als politiker das ist die
politik den bürgern schuldig und wir
sehen auch mit sorge die gesellschafts
politischen spannungen die sich aus
dieser maßnahmen politik ergeben die wir
ja eben auch für hoch verfassungswidrig
halten dementsprechend werden wir auch
dagegen klagen mit allen mitteln wir
halten ja auch zweig für rechtswidrig
jetzt ja auch umgesetzt im deutschen
bundestag ist ja auch zu einer spaltung
unserer fraktion führt die ein müssen
unten sitzen die anderen müssen oben
sitzen und ungeimpfte fliegen jetzt ja
sogar schon aus den ausschüssen hinaus
so kann es nicht weitergehen wir werden
an unserem parlamentarischen recht der
teilhabe
gehindert und dementsprechend werden
auch millionen von weder interessen
ignoriert aber es gibt eben auch eine
zeit nach corona das sehen wir ganz klar
wir müssen positiv in die zukunft
schauen und da müssen wir uns mit den
fragen auseinandersetzen wie eben schon
genannt steuerpolitik eine vernünftige
wirtschaftspolitik einen ordnungsrahmen
setzen für eine freiheitliche
wirtschaftspolitik